let's bring in our diplomatic editor
James Mays he's joining us from the
United Nations so what would you say has
been the main takeaway message from the
ambassadors after the closed-door
meeting I'm afraid it's a message that
we've heard so many times when it comes
to Syria in the last 8 and 1/2 years and
it's not really differed even though we
have the new development of the Turkish
military operation and that is deep
division in the UN Security Council you
just have to look at the fact that the
Security Council was meeting an open
session for a meeting about Colombia and
when they decided to discuss Syria they
went from the main security council
chamber into the consultation rooms next
door where they have the closed sessions
of the Security Council I think they
didn't want their divisions to be on
display you heard from the European
Union you heard what was said in their
statement a moment ago and it's clear
that there was a lot of wrangling behind
the scenes to come up with that EU
statement among the five members of the
Security Council who are from the
European Union and certainly France and
Germany wanted the strongest language
France I'm told didn't want to any
mention of what Turkey had done over the
last eight years in terms of its role
taking in so many refugees a lot of
wrangling there one assumes there was a
lot of wrangling potentially in the US
administration because the u.s. also
made their statement at the end of the
meeting and of course it had to take
into account that the u.s. position
seems to have evolved in recent days
after that initial White House statement
following the talks between President
Trump and president Erdogan on Sunday
which some say gave the green light to
Turkey to launch its operation this is
what was finally said by the u.s.
Ambassador Turkey is now responsible for
ensuring that all Isis fighters in
detention in prison remain in prison and
that Isis does not reconstitute itself
in any way shape or form
failure to play by the rules to protect
vulnerable populations failure to
guarantee that Isis cannot exploit these
actions to reconstitute will have
consequences you didn't hear any
statement from the President of the
Security Council speaking in his
capacity as the president representing
all of the council because if he's going
to read out words at the end of one of
these closed meetings every Security
Council member has to sign on to those
words and I can tell you the Russian
ambassador Vasily no Ben Zia told
reporters that they wanted if there was
to be a statement one that covered all
the issues of Syria and not just this
particular issue of recent days so again
clear division among the Security
Council
all right so James Mays thank you let's
get an update from Charles Stratford
who's joining us from act Akali that's
near a Turkey's border with Syria and
we've seen pictures Charles a fires
raging along that border area but can
you tell us about the state of the
operation right now well certainly the
last couple of hours it has been
relatively calm in this area certainly
in relation to the incredible
bombardment earlier in the day I'm just
hearing what sounds to be machine gun
fire in the distance the Turkish army
have been along this border telling
civilians on this side to stay in their
homes
we understand according to the
authorities that at least or maybe up to
nine civilians have been killed by
incoming artillery fire from across the
border we understand also that this
humanitarian crisis that we hear James
talking about in the UN is right at the
forefront of of aid agencies and people
who work in the humanitarian sphere in
this region and around the world 15
humanitarian aid agencies have come
together and a warning of a massive
crisis and they give some figures just
to put some context
what what the Syrians are facing across
the border they say that there's an
estimated 450,000 civilians live within
5 kilometers of the border around ninety
thousand of them have been internally
displaced and these aid agencies are
trying to put as much pressure as they
can on the international community to
force Turkey to take great
responsibility in obviously avoiding
hitting civilian areas and acting as
they described it according to
international law but as we heard from
James and certainly evidence on the
ground would suggest here that's going
to be very difficult to do the Turks say
that they are targeting SDF targets SDF
military what they describe as
terrorists they say that they're trying
to set up this safety zone to try and
rehouse some of the 3.6 million refugees
living in this country but when you're
getting statements being made by such a
large amount of humanitarian
organizations so concerned for all those
hundreds of thousands of Syrians across
the border it just shows you you know
what these people potentially are facing
as we heard in Dana's package thousands
that we understand have already started
fleeing their homes the town tell RB out
behind me he hasn't had electricity now
for at least 24 hours we saw it getting
heavily bombarded earlier today and
literally in the last few minutes we
have heard certainly according to our
sources that the Turkish authorities in
this area
are now trying to push the media back to
what we believe they think will be a
safer area now what that smells for the
next few hours remains to be seen but
the situation very tense here and
obviously a very frightening situation
across the border okay Charl Stratford
thank you for that update I mean while
US President Donald Trump has doubled
down on his decision to withdraw troops
saying he's trying to end what he calls
an endless war Kimberly halket has the
latest reaction from Washington u.s.
President Donald Trump taking to Twitter
on
Thursday morning a series of two tweets
where he indicated he's talking to both
Turkey as well as the Kurds the Kurds of
course have been a reliable ally of the
United States in recent years in the
effort to defeat ISIL many in the United
States believing that this decision to
pull back and allow Turkey to conduct
its military operation has essentially
let down a very valuable and loyal ally
to the United States the US president
has been pushing back on that suggestion
also noting in this tweet that in his
views the Turkish people as well as the
Kurds have been fighting in his words
forever
and the United States should not be
injecting itself into an historic
conflict now having said that the United
States president also cautioning Turkey
if there are what the US President
believes are inhumane or large civilian
casualties he has endorsed movement in
the US Senate by a member of his own
Republican Party as well as a Democratic
senator to sanction Turkey that effort
could be voted on as early as next week
would not only potentially limit
military sales to Turkey but could also
sanction at the highest levels including
president air Dewan his financial assets
and even limit the ability for the
leadership to obtain visas to enter the
United States